Had an ear infection in a four month old was given a medication is now having diarrhea and rash
So again an ear infection in a little child
You know such a slim chance that it's a bacterial for them to give you an
anti-macterial drug
It's just going to cause gut issues so and now they have diarrhea and a rash
So they you have to make sure that you if you're breastfeeding this four-month-old child that you're getting good
Probiotics you're getting a heavy to good diet with with different as many different types of food as you possibly can
You know a variety diet is super important for your gut health and your flora health
You're not going to just build your floor by taking a probiotic
It's it's a variety of foods in your diet is really really important
That's going to pass through
The breast milk hopefully your breastfeeding and that's going to help your child
I would not give a child an antibiotic of this I knew that they had a
Bacterial infection. I'm not against using antibiotics. It's just responsible use of antibiotics
You got to you don't use a antibiotic. Let's you know that you know that you know that you have a bacterial infection
There can be other environmental things for these things too one thing is
Mold in the household we run a mycotox test, which is a urine test done a lot of our members and
It's amazing how many people come out positive with that
There's mold in their house. There's mold exposure that you know
They've been exposed to at some point in their life a mycotox test is attested for active mold in the person's body
It's tested for toxins that the mold produces so if you have mycotoxins
Those are poisons that are produced by different molds. So you're going to get into your food
You're either getting you're getting a moldy mid building syndrome type thing
Or you're exposed to them in your past house that you live in or past workplace or church or something like that
You've got to deal with it because things are poisons in their bed